foreign
let's go to devony uh who is joining us
in Myrtle Beach South Carolina how can
we help
I have been struggling with a budget for
what feels like forever I've used every
dollar I've listened to the books just
recently started listening to the
podcast but I still can't seem to stay
on a budget and get us out of debt well
are you in good hands today with George
camel okay so tell me where where you
feel like you're failing with this
we set the budget and then we go over it
so we'll set it for let's say food and
then we go over that or we set it for
um let's say entertainment and we spend
it on something else or something else
comes up okay so let's take the food
category this is an easy one to to
Grapple with so you have the food what's
your food budget every month
that you said I don't know what to said
it as that's the problem too is I
was like how many months have you been
doing this
we've been on and off trying to set a
budget for three years probably like
it's just never so what's the if you
look back at how much you spent last
month or the month before give me an
average are you spending 500 and you're
setting it for 250
uh well we probably it kind of
fluctuates so let's say we spend 400 or
800 on food eating out and groceries and
all of that stuff are you guys trying to
get out of debt what's the goal here
with doing the budget yeah yeah we have
insane amounts of debt so why are we
eating out that's part of the problem
we are too lazy to cook at home
we're getting some answers now yeah this
is not a budgeting issue
yeah you're not focused do you guys
really want to get out of debt or is it
just kind of an ish is it just like ah
it'd be nice
no it's it's Weighing on us
so when you get in that car and you go
out to eat do you feel like a shame and
guilt afterwards where you're like man
gosh we just blew 60 bucks we could have
ate at home but we just our brains are
foggy from Warwick we didn't want to
cook that's normal right that's how I
feel after I order extra fries
been there and so we've got to adjust
our behavior and create the right habits
when it comes to budgeting so let's say
you set it for two 200 bucks and we're
not eating out that's our grocery budget
for the week now we go all right we
gotta stick to that we have to track
what we're actually spending and so are
you tracking each transaction in the
budget or is it just kind of you said it
yeah go over it at the end of the month
you have some shame and then you repeat
the process
yeah the letter
well know that you are not alone and
budgeting's hard it's it's kind of fun
when you make it and it looks great on
paper and then having to stick to it is
very difficult and so I'm gonna I'm
gonna jump in here George budgeting is
not hard it's behaving within the budget
is what so yeah we can all make the
Excel spreadsheet but then not eating
out after a long week that's the
difficult part that's the sacrifice and
so this is going to take some forward
planning it's going to take sacrifice
because right now you have a pile of
debt how much debt do you have
um not including our house with student
loans and other Consumer Debt like 214
000. 214 000. yep what's the bigger
debts in there
we've got two car payments and an RV
and then we've got like 11 000 in credit
card debt what's your household income
uh about 120. what's what's the RV worth
about 26. what do you owe on it
uh 23 I believe what about the car loans
what's the cars worth and what do you
all want them
um we owe 25 and 19 and they're both
worth about just that like I think I
might be upside down
all right first things first we're going
to sell the RV today
that's a depreciating asset and at least
you're we hope you're you you're not
upside down on that one
no we're not upset we're getting rid of
how much money do you guys have in the
bank
um we've got about
probably two thousand dollars okay
if I'm you guys I'm saving up for a cash
car a beater to get around two of them
and I'm selling this whole kit and
caboodle
you make 120 you have almost double that
in just Consumer Debt
no wonder you guys are eating out you're
stressed out to your eyeballs you can't
even think straight yeah you know but
George I I really I want them to I agree
with your advice but I want her to sell
the RV today let's get some momentum yes
like because that one we don't we got to
spend we got to save up some money and
replace the cars you don't have to do
Jack squat to sell the RV and then you
come away with three grand that George
will tell you what to do with three
grand what's your what are your payments
add up to servicing all that Consumer
Debt each month oh God
it's probably like twelve hundred
dollars or more so 1200 bucks to keep up
with the payments what's your take-home
pay
um it varies I'm I'm self-employed and
then my husband's a firefighter so it
depends on his way if he works overtime
or not what are you doing 400 it could
be 2000. I'm a photographer okay so can
you step up your photography game for a
year after we sell this RV
I mean I'm so
also can we charge more can we do some
specials how about do something else in
between trying to grow the photography
business let's go make some money
the great news about this is this is
solvable
getting rid of the cars in the RV is the
game changer
have you cut up the credit cards yet and
close the accounts
no I I thought I got stuck in that you
have to have your credit your credit
score so I like left them all open for
what until I I well I didn't know that
you didn't really need a credit score
which I listened to the episode the
other day okay well then today we can
cut up those cards they're not a
blessing in your life they're not a
crutch they're not for emergencies they
are keeping you broke
right so my goal for you we sell the RV
we get the income up we stick to the
budget and the way we do that is by
actually caring about the end result of
doing the budget which is to get out of
this mess and so at every turn every
time a transaction comes out of your
bank you've got to ask yourself is this
worth continuing to be in debt stressed
out not where we want to be not where we
should be you guys make six figures and
it all goes out to lenders every month
and so you've got to really find that
why Channel it and then that'll help you
go all right we're gonna be we're gonna
start meal planning we're not going out
to eat we're cutting every subscription
no more travel for the year we are gonna
batten down the hatches and get out of
debt once and for all and if you start
doing this stuff and you might need to
sell the cars once you have enough cash
to get the beaters that's going to help
you climb out of this pile and see the
light at the end of the tunnel so hang
on the line I'm gonna send you every
dollar premium which will connect to
your bank there's a paycheck planning
tool it will help you finally get
control of your money so hang on the
line Austin will gift that to you to
help you on the journey thanks for the
call